hello i'm nicholas hoult here with GQ
magazine to answer some of your
questions alright that's good do you
enjoy giving people advice not really to
be honest with you I don't think people
should listen to my advice and most of
the time people don't really want advice
anyway they just want to hear what they
want worst piece of advice you've ever
gotten
drink more I haven't had this shot do
that sort of thing that's generally bad
advice for me and peer pressure I always
give in to that best piece of advice
you've ever gotten go home when should
you split a check when should you never
split check yes you should always offer
to spellcheck I think always offer but
there's a lot of complications in that
question because you you know you have
to take into account where you've gone
who decide on the place how expensive
the place is who ordered what that's um
that's a difficult question to answer
but always offer how can I tell my new
girlfriend she needs two ladies get more
all right
I'm not asking for her to be completely
clean totally shaving down there but a
little more maintenance would be nice I
can't be dealing with that I have a
friend who is terrible at making plans
he's never free when I asked if he wants
to do something I mean the answers
already here really if he's never free
when he wants to do something probably
not really a friend in advance but then
calls me Oh then calls me at the blue
and expects me to be available to hang
out right away I feel I'm his bro
sidepiece Am I yes you are his bro
sidepiece my girlfriend's always
bringing her friends along in our dates
she tons sometimes gives me a heads up
sometimes she doesn't how can I tell my
girlfriend that I don't want to date her
friends oh ok put a positive spin on it
that you want to spend more time with
her alone time quality time yeah just
say that and then you know positive
always be positive
so thank you very much for all your
questions I hope I was as useless at
answering them as expected and that
everything goes well in all your lives